[Music]
just like many ukrainians in america and
all over the world we also have family
and we have friends that are living in
in the ukraine i don't know what to say
to my friends saying sorry sounds stupid
saying i understand i don't your guilt
will not help them
[Music]
hey what's up this is john with the dr
john delony show
man
hope you're doing well
hope your family's all right hope you're
safe hope you all are doing okay
if you want to be on the show give me a
shout at one eight four four six nine
three three two nine one that's one
eight four four six nine three thirty
two ninety one or you can go to
johndaloni.com
ask we got a pack packed show today so
i'm gonna go straight to the phones
let's go to k in des moines in des
moines what's up k
hey how are you i'm good how are you
good
so what's up how can i help
um we lost our
six-year-old son a couple years ago oh
good grief what happened
um he went
swimming with some friends oh man and he
drowned i'm so sorry what was his name
yeah it was it was rough um his sister
was there with with them it was um my
younger two kids that went with
and um the adult that had him
just wasn't watching him she was over
sun tanning and my kid was off
so anyway but my question is like my
oldest will be 18 pretty soon and
he has not
handled the loss that well
he has gone through a roller coaster the
lowest of his life
and i just don't know where i just don't
know how i can help him anymore um we've
even tried to send him into an inpatient
treatment um he got kicked out of that
we're trying to get him into a place
right now
but they are looking at his past
he is ready as can be he wants to go
but i don't know what else i can do for
him um places won't take him and i don't
even know how i can even
help him as a mom anymore
i'm so sorry what a mess
um let me ask a couple of background
questions how many how many kids do you
have total
um i had three
three so you had an 18 year old
held your your daughter
uh she's 14 okay and then kaden would
have been eight
yep okay and would was that is that
three
yep yep and my oldest who doesn't turn
18 until june okay um and so that's why
we're coming into some issues as well so
what's been going on is he using is he
if he's getting kicked out of treatment
centers that means he's got violent
tendency like what's been going on
um
it started with drinking he was drinking
a lot at first when the accident
happened
um like daily
and then he kind of had a scare and then
he led into what was the scare
he got really really wasted and
he
um
passed out like i found him in his truck
uh like 1 30 in the morning um he had no
kind of no idea where i was who i was or
what was going on and it just kind of
scared him because he drove yeah like 20
to 30 miles from where he was supposed
to been staying at and so
that kind of scared him well then it led
into
um
he led him to marijuana um
and so then
he was trying to do that to cover up his
pain
before all of this he he was a very good
a
b student
did all sports had a great group of
friends
um after the accident he lost all of
that he had no motivation he didn't do
sport his
grades got a different crowd of girl
kids
how did your home
how did your home grieve
is dad at home
yeah yeah okay so how did
dad grieve how did you grieve
um to be honest i don't think we had
have had a chance to okay
um
we kept pushing and pushing to be
to be active to be busy at all times
because we had two kids that were
grieving
and we wanted to make sure that they
were okay um
and so i honestly i don't think we even
have had the chance because
since the accident
we both
have been dealing with now our oldest
and then also trying to make life
okay for our daughter that has seen all
of this and was there you know
so
i'm going to talk to you because our
time is compressed i'm going to talk
real directly okay i need you to hear me
say you and i are on the same side of
the booth on this conversation okay
you promise that i can hear in your
voice how close caiden is still sitting
he's still on your chest
oh yeah okay
kayden's still in your home he's still
in your bed
right
okay so i'm gonna speak as though you
and i have talked for a couple of weeks
okay
um and i need you to promise me
something say i promise
i promise
that what i'm about to say is not gonna
be guilt-inducing because that's where
you're gonna go with it okay
okay
this is about tools and what i mean by
tools is
um
i had a friend over this weekend helping
me use a chainsaw on to cut down a tree
and
i was trying to do something with an axe
and he pulled out like a hammer and i
felt like an idiot because i was using
the wrong tool okay
and so all we're talking about is tools
here
you promise you you trust me
yep okay
um
first and foremost you've got a teenage
son who you love and it feels like
you're losing another kid
i want you to own that level of gravity
okay
is that does that sound close to home
oh yeah
we've actually mentioned that it feels
like we lost them okay feels like you're
losing your your second son okay
in some ways you are but in many ways
you aren't i also want to take drugs and
alcohol huge deal terrifying deal all
that scary
and here's why i'm not super concerned
about that right this second because
drugs and alcohol work those are the
solutions to his challenges those aren't
the problem right now okay you're gonna
have to deal with the alcohol addiction
and those things when you when but
that's for the professionals and y'all
will get there
often
often parents when they lose a child
they double down and say we've got to
help our other kids and what we want to
do is make things as quote unquote
normal as possible
we don't want them to lose their
childhood because of this we don't want
them to miss out on these experiences
and so a very common narrative usually
at barbells it's one or the other it's
usually
either people shut down and just are
encased in amber like just stuck in
syrup or
everybody says we're gonna keep going
going going we will grieve when the kids
go to college we'll do that later
and what can happen not always but what
can happen
is i'm just gonna use your oldest son
i'm gonna name him tom okay
okay
tom looks around his environment
and he does not see anybody exhibiting
what is going on in his body which is
darkness which is a hole which is
a the vacuum that you feel when somebody
so close to you goes away
throw in sister was there and the you
should have been there well i didn't
know that kind of stuff throw when an
adult was there an adult's job is to
keep make sure everybody's okay right so
you throw all that complexity in there
and you've got a 16 year 17 year old
screaming from the inside out
and the greatness sounds
counterintuitive the single greatest
gift you can give that 16 year old is
not normalcy because nothing is normal
anymore
what you can give that kid
is
weeping from the bottom of your gut
and holding him
letting him see you and your husband
weep and say we're not going out this
week we're all just staying in
because what it does for the 16 year old
is it gives him permission to go oh my
god my feelings are normal
i'm not crazy
and what happens over the course of a
couple of years when somebody's deep in
grief
and everyone around them looks like
they're just going on about their day or
trying to have some sense of normalcy
you the pain becomes overwhelming
because now you're isolated now you're
alone
and so this isn't an advice situation
this isn't a
here's the things i didn't tell you
this is about we're going to start
saying cadence name in our home a lot
this is about we are going to all as a
family write letters to caden
tell them how much we miss them
and mom and dad are going to read their
letters to
to brother and sister
and we might not be able to get through
the first one or the second one or the
third one and we might write him a
letter that says i'm so can't believe i
let you go with such and such adult
and i you are still wearing a lot of
grief and and uh
and guilt too i can feel it on you okay
but these family discussions these this
this breathability lets caden make his
way through the hearts and minds and
synapses and blood and air of everyone
in that home and right now he's trapped
you hear what i'm saying
and what i'm saying sounds real real
woo-woo
and you've probably had to build some
really strong scaffolding to
get through the last few years
if i'm you in your situation where i
would start
is a with my son
with my oldest son
and say
we're going to start with a letter to
caden you and me and i'm not even go as
far as to say is um
hey we i've tried to do my best and we
missed this one and i'm going gonna
start now by
um we're gonna grieve this thing and
we're gonna do it together
and i would let your son breathe
and he might have does he is he is he
had an alcohol addiction he had a drug
addiction
um
[Music]
yes and no i guess i guess it's not as
bad anymore because he's been in a
treatment okay
um and so he
hasn't been like really bad it's more of
the mental issues that he has like if
something triggers him yeah
then he might go in the house okay some
drinks or something like that but it's
mainly his mental and he knows he can be
clean it's just
sure so it's it's this it's that it's
that black hole vacuum
of loss
and it's the isolation it's the nobody
else in this house seems to be feeling
this
some kids will go get straight a's with
that feeling some kids will
turn to alcohol and weed because it just
into pills because it just makes things
a little less sharp
but i think your home
starting with you and husbands
and this is hard because
here's what i know about you okay and
i'm not not you about mothers in this
situation
there's this sense that if i start
crying i will never be able to stop
if i drop my shoulders i'm out i'm done
and i'll tell you two things number one
you're right you will cry for caden for
the rest of your life
and
you will find strength and resilience in
your community and in people around you
and in yourself that you did not know
existed
you've got to walk towards caden you've
got to walk towards your oldest son
you've got to walk towards your husband
and your husband's got to walk in the
middle of all this too
so what your family i believe needs
deeply is a
no more running
this is who we are this is where we are
we've experienced this great trauma this
great tragedy we're gonna talk to cayden
and at some point
it's gonna be a while
at some point okay you and your husband
y'all are gonna let caden go
you let him go home
and right now you're hanging onto him
real real real real tight
i'm so so sorry
as it goes for your son
hang in there with the treatment
let him be a part of this grieving
process
if he's struggling with deep mental
health issues talk to that talk to his
counselor about this stuff okay
um don't give him things don't let him
be in situations you can't handle but
tell the tell his counselor
the family's ready to start grieving
this and we have it in a long time
and we're gonna start today we'll be
right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you've got an expert in
a team who have your back listen if
you're about to buy a home and make a
big change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple h
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in the mls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we are back let's go to chris
in omaha what's up christopher
how are you sir good to be here thank
you brother what's up man
man it's an honor um so i am a former
teacher i know i'm an author speaker
comedian i work with a lot of schools in
building resilient kids uh mentally
social emotional learning uh that that
whole realm
and um
i i know uh oppositional defiance
disorder uh i know it's a clinical
diagnosis
but
uh myself and my wife as you know uh
good christian parents we like to think
of ourselves um
i
i'm looking for your opinion
um on you like to think of yourselves as
what
good parents as good
good christian parents all right good
christian
i can't wait for this you set it up well
so what's the
one for the payoff here
i'm wondering uh your your professional
opinion oppositional defiance disorder i
know it's a clinical diagnosis but
where
i i guess my question is
it seems like it
it's more of an excuse over the last
number of years for
um
a lack of parenting skills uh at least
from from my vantage point and i'm just
looking to get your opinion on that
where you stand on on stuff like that
okay um so i'll give you a rundown but i
want to make sure the line is clear here
so
as good christian parents you're raising
your kids
to fill in the blank when it comes to
behavior and response and all that and
so their fault they are living up to
your expectations that you're setting as
good christian parents other kids are
out of control
exhibiting these behaviors at school
um
lashing out you know being ugly with
teachers violence those kind of things
and the line is back to
people who aren't serving as good
christian parents is that kind of is
that is that the truth is that the line
here i want to make sure i'm answering
your question
well the line is more of uh it seems to
me that the the boundary has been moved
back to kind of make a
an excuse for the disrespect the
um
uh
i guess the overall disrespect and the
behavioral issues and they've put a
label on it now of you know the
oppositional defiance disorder gotcha
okay
okay so
i'm gonna start by by answering it this
way
uh i may have i don't know if i've told
this on the show or not i don't
i don't know i feel like i repeat myself
all the time maybe i don't
so when my son was born um i just
graduated with my first phd and there's
nothing worse than someone who just
graduates with a graduate school the
worst i was an idiot i just put it on
everything on my email signature told
everybody i was i was annoying
and my wife has a phd she's brilliant
and her scholarship her research was
about um working with kids
and
so when my son comes along
we were older we waited a while and then
it took us years to
actually have him
he comes along
and he's pretty much perfect we were
incredible and i remember at some point
at like age two or three
i was like
i think every other parent's an idiot
um
why are we even working at universities
we should go on the road and write the
greatest parenting book because everyone
else is stupid
and my wife in her classic way she deals
with me is she just nods and just goes
on about her day because she knows that
she married
a [ __ ]
and
i really was like man why is this so
hard like just to have high expectations
and then have high discipline and have a
high accountability and
whatever
and then my daughter came along
and i don't know where she's from it is
not here it's not here and i realized in
short order oh we just rolled the dice
well the first one actually we've rolled
the dice incredible with a second one
too they're just different kids so i
prefaced it with that to tell you this
i think like adhd like oppositional
defiant disorder like
much of anxiety depression is out there
on its own so i'm not going to mess with
that one in this call
because that's got all kinds of other
things going on with it
i think a number of these diagnostics
are
have turned gone from label to
i'm trying to think of the right word
off top of my head label to
core issue
instead of representing an environment
okay so what you're at what your
question is i think is not really the
right question because you're asking an
either or question is this real or is
this if parents would just suck it up
and start parenting their kids right
this would go away and the answer is
more complex than that
i'll answer
true odd yeah you know me true
oppositional defined disorder right
um it's a diagnosis and it's it there is
no test for it there is no you can't
take draw blood for it right it is not
rendered lightly
to quote an article it's not rendered
lightly it is it takes a while to come
to this this thing
and so now especially in schools we do
have people who throw this label all
over the place no question about it
if you've ever met a truly odd child you
go
oh
so to answer is it real yes
is it over um
diagnosed i think probably 10x
but here's where that i don't like
saying that out loud
because it's the kids who pay for it not
their school systems and not their
parenting systems and not their
grandparenting systems and not their
legacy trauma issues
because when we say something like yeah
you don't really have options for
oppositional defiant disorder
we take a dysregulated child and a
dysregulated child is just telling you
they're not safe and they're not
connected and they're not okay they got
nobody looking out for them they got
nobody on their team
and that can be everything from a school
that starts at 6 15 a.m and the kid has
no sleep
because mom is working three jobs and
the babysitter maybe shows up most of
the time and brings a half a box of
macaroni right so you've got nutritional
you've got sleep you've got supervision
you've got all kinds of things
that has a stable parenting home of two
where
y'all make enough money that somebody
that things are able to happen in a
certain way okay so that's my loose
answer to say
yes when it's real it's super super real
super real
like chemically neurologically real and
i think many kids are desperate for
boundaries desperate for accountability
but underneath all that they are
desperate
to be looked in the eyes and told they
are loved and to be shown they are loved
through
food and sleep and accountability and
hard work and throwing a ball and moms
and dads putting their cell phones down
and grandparents not um abusing mom and
dad still is that you hear what i'm
saying now
yeah absolutely and that kind of where i
was leaning i just
you know i wanted to hear the
professional opinion yeah um but yeah i
agree probably you know way over
diagnosed but there are legit cases and
i
so i am fat i'm joining a chorus of
professionals
who are moving
wholesale away from 95 percent of
diagnostics because they're simply not
helpful number one
number two
you've got
uh it's not like you take a strep test
you go to any number of counselors and
they're gonna give your psychology
they're going to give you different
diagnostics or depending on which
inventory they give you they're going to
come up with so
that whole
the whole spectrum of diagnostics i
think is is under fire here and it
should be
and i think the the chorus of blame so
if you hear my show i rarely blame i
rarely go after like you parents need to
and except when it comes to cell phones
and screens yeah then i get after people
but
it's bigger than that so instead of
saying hey you know what you just did
you did this what i want to do is i want
to give people a bunch of tools and say
make your kid go to bed at 7 15
until they're in high school or 7 30
or absolute max 8 and they're going to
think it's child abuse or if you miss
hanging out with your kid because you
don't have community or you don't have
these things
make your kids
do chores which means
this happened to me the other day
i got i went into my son's room i was
like what like how do you live like this
and i walked down the hall into my room
and i thought
i learned it by watching you dad right i
have to i have to do these things too if
i say don't walk past the dog's bowl
when does that have any food and water
just fill it up then that means i got to
stop and do it every day right so i'm
talking about let's give parents some
tools and grandparents some tools and
communities some tools and schools some
tools for wholesale change
not just saying that's not even real
y'all need to suck you hear what i'm
saying
yep absolutely all right so that's my
that's my
it is real it is over diagnosed i think
the important thing to do right now is
to tell kids that we love them and to
show them we love them
and god i can say that over and over
again show your kids you love them
show your kids you love them
hold their hands read their dumb stories
put your phones
away
let them mow the yard with you even
though it's gonna take eight times
longer let them clean the car with you
which is gonna take a thousand more
years and you can't cuss when you find
old gum in the seat you just gotta take
it because you're gonna be a grown-up
my son and daughter came and said hey
can we climb up on top of the barn we
stacked a bunch of buckets together and
i was
how about y'all use the ladder
i didn't want them but they need to do
hard things they need to be able to fall
down
love your kids show them that you'll
love them
we'll be right back
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care we spend time
energy money on everyone else but when
it comes to making time for vacation for
exercise for talking with a mentor for
sleep even going to therapy
we don't do it and we don't even realize
they won't even think about it
you are worth it
this month better help online therapy
wants to remind you that you are
important
that you are worth being well and
therapy is a super important way you can
show up for yourself better help is
online therapy that offers video phone
even live chat sessions with your
therapist you don't even have to see
anyone on a camera if you don't want to
it's more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours today dr
john deloney show listeners get 10
percent off their first month so decide
to invest in yourself
you are worth it and go to
betterhelp.com
deloney to get 10 off that's
betterhelp.com
delony
all right we are back let's go to aleona
in south carolina what's up eliana
hi dr john how are you i'm good how are
you i am all right thank you of course
how are you
so
um
never mind i was gonna ask you something
totally unrelated so go ahead go ahead
um well first i would like to thank you
and your team and all mental health
professionals for
walking with us every day as we heal and
so we can better serve our communities
and our families i really mean it with
all my heart and gratitude so thank you
hey i am running a like a podcast in a
radio show the truth therapists who are
in there seven hours eight hours a day
every day they're incredible yeah you
are right high five to them thank you so
much so what's up
so today i'm hoping that you can share
some thoughts on how i can best provide
mental and emotional support
um to my dear family and friends who are
currently
fighting for their lives and fighting
for their homes in the ukraine
oh
man
tell me about what's going on
um
so i'm i'm very lucky and fortunate and
blessed to live here in the united
states
i do have some family that lives here
but
just like many ukrainians in america and
all over the world we also have family
and we have friends that are living in
in the ukraine and
we are able to help them financially i'm
very blessed that i can
and we're sending humanitarian help
but normally if someone is having a hard
time i can sit here and hold their hand
and listen and
talk to talk to them but i i don't know
how to talk to my family i don't know
what to say to my friends because
saying sorry sounds stupid
in saying i understand i don't
i i don't understand
so i'm hoping that i can
find a way to be there for them
thousands of miles away and
maybe a way to be here for my family and
my community in the united states
they're also having a hard time oh man
well number one thank you for sharing
that and
you are intimately tied to this
tragedy that's going on and
um you're speaking on behalf of millions
who aren't as intimately tied they don't
have friends or family that are there
but they're just watching this and the
word that keeps going through my heart
and mind here is powerless
this sense that you are watching
bombs and tanks roll over your
neighborhoods and your homes and
children being born in bomb shelters and
things and this sense of powerlessness
you couldn't get there if you wanted to
right so there's there's just literally
nothing to do it's like watching
somebody drown and
you can't jump in right
and it's just that sense of
powerlessness and then you label i mean
you put on top of that that survivor's
guilt
because you're doing you all are living
well in the u.s and there's a part of
you that thinks that feels bad about
that tell me about that
i
i
on what
i i learned this concept from you both
and
number one i am absolutely grateful
and blessed to be here and i'm grateful
that i am safe and my mama is safe my
father's safe
and i am
incredibly hurt and devastated and
guilty over the fact that i'm sitting
here in a
nice apartment with
you know with my dogs i i have a way to
pay my bills and even go to restaurants
and i
how how do
how do you
i can't get over that i i
i just want i want to fly there and
fight that's what i want to do and
that's what many of us
absolutely yes if they said hey any uh
folks who want to hop on a plane we'll
fly you over
yes those planes would be packed
right so
um
i'm gonna speak super honestly with you
is that okay
of course okay
you are man you are a brave brave woman
i'm so grateful that you called
so
here's the bold statement i'm going to
say and i'm going to preface this with
this is a privilege statement this is a
fill in any kind of critique you want to
say about this statement
but this is the truth okay
right
there's nothing you can say to them
beyond i love you
with a period you will not have peace
until this is over
period
your guilt
will not help them
the greatest gift you can give them
is joy
and living your life here and here's why
we often think that pain is some zero
and joy is some zero
and
if we've got a friend who is hurting a
friend who's in the hospital a friend
who's overseas while their home is being
invaded by a foreign country
that we need to
slide into that with them
and if they're our neighbor like you
said you're dang right man i'm going
into that house i'm gonna sit with them
in their ugliest moments i'm gonna make
casseroles and
cheap cookies and i'm going to walk
alongside them
when it's one of these paralyzing
there's nothing we can do here
our instinct is to do the same
because our bodies aren't designed to
know in watch in real time on cell
phones something that's going on 15 000
miles away on the other side of the
world
and so our bodies have a pain and and
for loved ones and slide in to help
response and we are trying to do that
now and we can't
and we think that if we have if we laugh
if i go to a nice restaurant if i
do something romantic with my husband if
i fill in the blank
that somehow we are taking joy from them
right
and that couldn't be further from the
truth so flip it around
if you were there
would you want somebody who you loved
who had the
the cosmic blessing of being out of
there
to just be miserable or would you want
them to go have dinner
oh i would want them to live their life
and i would join i would want them to
live wheels off
you better go out cause i'm stuck here
in a bunker right you know what i mean
hey
and so
i want to challenge you to
put more beauty into the world in a time
when
millions of people are
um under fire and smoke and gray
put joy into the world put laughter into
the world put beauty into the world
where you can
lashing yourself
in order for camaraderie only results in
wounds on your back it doesn't help them
do you hear what i'm saying
yes yes ma'am can i give you one other
hard hard piece of wisdom
oh absolutely and this is the pot
talking to the kettle here do you know
that expression
no but i am going to google it
afterwards here's what the pot talking
to the kettle is
this is somebody who is going to be very
hypocritical for a second
actually you know what i'm going to make
a commitment on this show with you if
you'll join me okay
since this kicked off
i have been obsessed
i have followed everything i've got a
curated twitter account i don't even
have twitter i go on the internets to
get through twitter but i follow a
curated feed
hours a day
i don't read the mainstream news because
they're not telling us the truth
whatever nonsense i've come up with and
i am obsessed with the talking to
military people talking to ukrainian
folks talking to russian i'm obsessed
with it
and here's what we have to do
we have to turn it off
right we have to turn it off
and that sounds so ugly and evil and
privileged in nonsense
we are not helping them
by just absorbing this 24 7 365.
the best thing we can do is be well
so that
we can rally people to provide money we
can tell the stories that aren't being
told we can write letters and they may
not get there
they may not make it there may not be a
mail service here that's going to get
them there we can write emails or we can
write texts that just say i love you i
love you i love you
i miss your face
not i'm sorry not um i understand yeah
none of that's true you're exactly right
i just i love you
and i'm putting beauty into the world
with your name on it
don't insert yourself into this combat
zone it doesn't help them it hurts you
can you and i make it make an agreement
that we're gonna cut back on how much
we're consuming
oh absolutely i um my family in general
and majority of our community that i am
around
we have
very consciously and intentionally
turned off
the news and we don't watch a lot of
news in general because everything we
need to know our friends and families
will tell us beautiful um
but
one thing that we are facing and this is
a product of misinformation
we are receiving a lot i mean
right now we're hurting our hearts are
breaking right and majority of majority
of the people rallied around us but we
are receiving a lot of hate
from
misinformation the
labs information nazis etc like that
makes it okay to kill innocence people
and children right
so what about that can you do anything
about
nothing at all
nothing at all you can turn it off
thanks you can turn it off
it's like people who are picketing
outside of a funeral
like i'm not gonna i'm not gonna give
you real estate in my head
i'm not gonna give you a voice at my
table
my friend died i don't care if you liked
him or not i'm gonna go in here and sit
with my friends family
and i'm gonna mourn and weep and then be
about honoring him and the best way i
know to honor people is to put beauty
into the world
and to laugh and to go dancing and to
eat well and to make sure people around
me are honored
and to make sure i'm a part of a process
that never allows us to happen on the
dirt of where where i sleep
right right
and so um
yeah there's misinformation out there
it's hard when somebody says something
ugly or evil about people you love
especially people you love who are
hurting
we tend to flock to that
right right cut it off turn it off
i'm gonna block you i will never speak
to you again have a great life i wish
you the best may the force be with you
and whatever other star wars references
you want to put in their life right i'm
just i'm just gonna be done with it i
miss out thanks
don't get a voice in my heart in my head
you know who does
my friends and my family my community
and
when i'm able to get a text message or a
face time with somebody who's sitting in
the middle of kiev and we could talk for
a minute
with the sirens not going off i'm gonna
cherish that moment and i'm just gonna
listen and i'm gonna say i love you i
love you i love you and i'm planting
flowers with your name on them and i'm
gonna go plant flowers
that's a great idea
blend sunflowers ukrainian flower
or whatever it is put beauty into the
world find get with your community with
your family with your friends and just
say where can we put beauty out here
number one we're going dancing
why because delony is the worst this guy
this podcast i listen to they don't
listen to it because it's not that great
but this podcast i listened to
um
he said to go dancing because he's a
terrible terrible terrible dancer and
the world needs better dancers so we're
going dancing and we're going to plant
flowers this weekend
so everybody we're going to the nursery
like what you know you hear what i'm
saying i love love your heart
let's just turn it off and this is me
talking to myself in the mirror so thank
you for holding a mirror up to me today
you've been a gift to me as well
if there's something that um
what's one thing you can pass along to
us to me
you're talking to people who are there
that aren't on the radio that are just
moms and dads and brothers and sisters
trying to figure out what in the world
is happening
um what would you pass along to us
um
you know i
the only regrets and it's funny you said
to tell people that you love them the
only thing i was thinking of on february
24th is
what was my last conversation with my
sister
and my brother and my nieces and nephews
and
when was the last time i talked to my
dear friends
and
it's that
right now i am trying to be intentional
about seeing my family here
in the united states and hugging my mom
closer because her
daughter is in the middle of the war and
my father's son is in the middle of the
war and
just hugging them closer
and letting go of things and spending
more time with our loved ones and
because
i don't i i was terrified that my last
conversation with my sister would have
been an argument and i couldn't remember
if i told her that i love her
and what will you never ever do as long
as you live again you'll never hang up
the phone without saying i love you will
you never no never i haven't i still
have not can i cannot can i tell you
something i'm just keeping him with
delony wisdom which is i just give the
same pieces of advice over and over and
over again you know it'd be really cool
it would be awesome if you and your mom
and dad
went and
way
overpaid for a really nice leather
journal and every day y'all wrote
your brother and your sister a letter
how much you miss him how much you're
thinking about him and when this thing's
over
and y'all are able to reunite and hug
again
you'll be able to hand them that journal
and they'll be able to see
that in spirit and in heart y'all were
with them
and y'all planted flowers all along the
way
i would love that sound good
absolutely all right i'm going to do
something for you i'm going to give you
a copy of um this new book that's coming
out okay and it's not fully out it will
be out in storage by the time the show
comes out i think but um it's here's
here's the the genesis of the book is or
the thesis is
here's how to own what's the garbage
that's going on right now and then
here's what to do next okay
and you and your family can just walk
through it together here's what we do
now all right this knucklehead says to
do this all right let's do this
uh
how do we grieve here's a chapter on
great so it's just gonna be a playbook
for the next
five months five years right as this
thing plays itself out and i need you to
hear me say eliana
we're standing with you we're praying
with you
and you've got my commitment to plant
some flowers and to put some joy into
the world
[Music]
thank you so much we'll be right back
[Music]
for the past two decades i've worked
with students parents those on the
margins and those who seem to have
everything i've met with law enforcement
military folks struggling single moms
company presidents and everybody in
between and there is one thread that
weaves through all of these different
people that you
me we
are so
lonely we don't have real in-depth safe
relationships and hear me say this you
cannot be well alone
you can't do life by yourself you got to
get connected to real life people and
have deep
relationships i'm talking relationships
where you can be yourself share hard
things and know you'll show up for one
another in my new book own your past
change your future we'll walk through a
not so complicated approach to
relationships mental health and wellness
and getting connected because it's a key
part of living a good life you'll learn
why shallowness and loneliness are so
dangerous you'll even learn how to start
making real friends so go to
johndaloney.com to take the next step
towards wellness that's own your past
change your future at johndaloni.com
all right we are
back with
do we have like any cool new music
we'll put it in post ah sweet all right
when this comes in there's gonna be some
rad new music for a new segment called
facts are your friends this comes from a
good
my good friend and really one of my most
important mentors of my life dr andy
young
he was a psychology professor of mine
but he's also
a
just someone who's helped me walk
through a lot in life and he trained me
on crisis response he's the one who let
me tag along for years with him and his
incredible team until he finally asked
me i could be on the team uh let me join
the team after i hassle him about it um
but one of the most common things we
would say he would say and remind us
over and over we would go into
situations where we're doing death
notifications where were
seeing the worst of the worst and
sitting with people who have just
experienced their lives implode
was facts of your friends facts to your
friends and so in this segment it's
gonna be a new segment that we're gonna
start doing these are simple
conversations about complex ideas
what's this diagnostic earlier on in
this show somebody called about
oppositional defiant disorder right so
we'll have different things about
diagnostics different things about hey
in this movie it said that so it's going
to be
simple conversations about pretty
complex things all right and so today
for the first inaugural facts of your
friends
man i'm really uh i'm crushing it huh
we're gonna be talking about narcissism
narcissist that guy's a narcissist oh my
gosh she's such a narcissist my
mother-in-law is a narcissist the number
of emails kelly gets about somebody's
mother-in-law being a narcissist or
somebody's dad being a narcissist and
then most recently
is putin a narcissist the leader of
russia is he a narcissist hey does he a
narcissist is he is he
so
let's take a step back
and look at what narcissist is
and then we're gonna get to is putin a
narcissist how about that
so narcissist is one of those terms
that's thrown around all over the place
super quick to throw this label on just
about everything
jerk narcissist somebody says something
we don't like narcissists somebody calls
and is like well come on narcissus we
just throw it around throw it around so
let's step back and look at what
actually narcissistic personality
disorder actually is
it's important to know when you're
dealing with a narcissist
their life is about them not you okay so
clinically narcissistic personality
disorder means someone has an inflative
sense of importance a need for
admiration a lack of empathy a sense of
entitlement at a pathological level okay
here's some common traits exaggerated
sense of self-important
um constant excessive need for
admiration fantasies of success and
power in brilliance beauty this sounds
like james monopolizing converse not
really james monopolizing conversations
and inability to recognize the feelings
and needs of others
the dsm
boy that's my favorite book
uh pervasive pattern of grandiosity a
need for admiration right believes they
are special requires excessive
admiration
my friend dr cloud henry cloud talks a
lot about narcissist
he suggests that
they have this inflated sense of
self-worth and people are always looking
to feel better
and so they get a new they they get what
they want at dinner and they need to
feel better again and then they
send the food back at the dinner table
they're not going to give me crap like
this and then they need to feel better
and so then they take it out on you and
then i'm not driving that car you drive
and it just it's this constant need to
get better and it crushes people and it
drains them and it leaves everybody
around them thinking there's something
wrong with them it's gaslighting you end
up feeling like you're not good enough
right
so
at the core fundamental level a
narcissist uses manipulation and
psychological control to get what they
want they live in a world of denial and
fantasy to avoid reality
this is an emotionally stunted person
somebody who stopped developing i like
to say it's the inner seven year old
they spit on things they hit things they
lash out at things they fantasize about
star wars and dragons
and
you know being a rock star and having a
certain body they're stuck at
seven-year-old level
like my daughter okay
they may treat people bad but their
lives aren't about other people it's
about them they are the focus of their
world others are just fuel for that
engine okay so here's a few important
notes narcissists rarely seek help
unless something important to them is at
stake and even then it's rare also not
all people with narcissistic personality
disorder bang drums all day they're not
all loud and brash and outwardly
confident and socially charming some are
shy
hypersensitive very thin skin very
fragile and they will drag you down
underwater
gently you don't even know it until
suddenly you're gasping for air
some come in loud and uh that's the one
on tv right
the one that many of us deal with is the
one that's slowly under
water right
now
most people
are not narcissists most people are
jerks
or morons
are kind of an idiot
that guy
is just a jerk
or
some people have just had things given
to them for long enough that they don't
have a psychology they don't have a
operator's manual for
um yellow are coming home for
thanksgiving um y'all gonna be here at
two right because we're gonna eat at
three so you only be here by two
hey mom we're not gonna come home for
thanksgiving this year actually we're
going to get a cabin out in the woods
and just go stay there because it's
going to be better for all of our souls
and then mom doesn't have an operator's
manual for that and so we're going to
teach her and we're going to lean into
that
all of us can be self-absorbed sometime
all this can be selfish
sometimes that's part of being human if
you're not worried
yeah
if you're worried that you're a
narcissist you're probably not
that's one of the core core functions
if you think someone close to you as a
narcissist
pay attention to how you feel in their
presence
pay attention to how they treat you and
others
and this is um as we get into like
the putin discussion
just stop saying narcissist
just stop with the diagnostic it's an
easier way to live
that diagnostic i believe is for
psychologists and psychiatrists and some
counselors and some family therapists
but it's overused and it's not always
helpful
it is helpful when you're teaching
somebody hey this is them doing
something to you you're being gaslighted
you're allowed to set boundaries i like
to
serve people by working at what you're
talking to them not about others so
sometimes it's important to point out
what other people are doing to you and
to say like hey that's not normal that's
not okay or that guy's abusive or that
guy the diagnostic stuff i just leave
off
i just leave it off
here's why
you deserve boundaries
you deserve to have your needs met you
deserve to be loved you deserve to not
be abused you deserve to
not find yourself being dragged under
water
so when people say
is putin a narcissist
i i'm not going to give that credence
i'm not a psychologist i'm not a
psychiatrist and that diagnostic label
doesn't help anybody you got a guy that
appears to have invaded a sovereign
country
and is trying to take it over and if he
can't take it over he is going to just
blow it all up
and he's going to take out women and
children and soldiers and babies and
infrastructure and monuments all of it
it's going to burn all the ground
and so i am going to deal with that
reality i don't care what the diagnostic
is
diagnostics are can be helpful but they
can also be used to blame they can also
be used to excuse
so i'm always going to look at behavior
right so going back to if you think
someone's a narcissist what do you do
how does your body feel when you're
around them do you get that feeling your
gut's like
this is not gonna then don't go that's
on you to set a boundary
focus on what you can control don't
diagnose people just stop diagnosing
people focus on what you can control and
especially kill this fantasy you can't
change other people
period you can't you can change you you
can't change your co-workers you can't
change your office mate you
i guess office mates and co-workers are
the same thing you can't
you can't change any of this stuff
except for you all right so that's our
first installment of facts are your
friends we're talking about narcissism
spend your life diagnosing people less
and setting firm boundaries and loving
yourself and others more just make that
a part of your life
i think that might be the most genius
thing i've ever said is it that makes
you sound like a narcissist
oh my gosh or at least a megalomaniac
i've never asked myself that question
james
cause maybe as we wrap up today's show
hey listen
this is my shout out
to brother t hawkins man
uh one of the greatest rock drummers of
all time who died this weekend um
suddenly um
number one my legit number one favorite
rock song of all time
it's called everlong by the foo fighters
and it goes like this we'll miss you
taylor
hello i've waited here for you ever long
tonight i throw myself in two and out of
the red out of her head she's saying
come down and waste away with me down
with me slow down you you wanted it to
be just how you want it to be i'm over
my head out of her head she's saying and
i wonder when i sing along with you
if anything could ever feel this real
forever if anything could ever be this
good again the only thing i'll ever ask
of you is you gotta promise not to stop
when i say win
we'll miss you taylor we'll see you soon
coming up on the next episode i have
like 150 pounds to lose in addition to
battling depression and anxiety sounds
to me like you're drowning
sounds to me like you're slowly
suffocating i do feel like i felt hated
i was kind of surprised recently when
the war with ukraine started
it just
kind of sucker punched me and took me
back to some of those major
places of anxiety so do you have major
life stuff going on
well i'm pregnant with our fifth child
twelve ten eight then jump down to two
and here's the buddy for the two years
and here's the buddy
[Music]